ich bin dran und zwar sage ich direkt
wenn ich du wäre würde ich einfach mal
unsere koordinaten in den chat schreiben
was kathrin regal
da war irgendwas magst ein gegner ist
zudem nahm das spiel zu verlassen ist
dann ist es hier
da kommen welche da kommen welche luca
[Musik]
da kommen sie da kommen sagt okay ich
bin hinter uns alter ich habe angst
macht wie kommen wir nicht hoch wie sie
gesagt ich hab's du hast wahrscheinlich
gegeben luca di dentro wie die treppe
hochlaufen oft love love love love love
love la roux mein gott nicht ins fliegen
und auf gar keinen fall ins nicken die
ganze sie kommen sie kommen
[Musik]
wahrscheinlich gesprächen halte weg von
mir hast du das gegrillte es ist einfach
so was wir machen
ich habe ein streik bekommen also als
wenn zombie wargame obama als wenn alle
oft schon der ganze server ist voll
wegen uns was soll das gezeigte aber
lava gameplay ausgeschnitten es ist
[Musik]
nicht zu mir komme ich zu mir
habe einer werbe ich glaube auch heute
das hat ich habe kein gutes gefühl
hallo mein name ist herzlich willkommen
wie heute zu einer neuen folge war wovon
ich war relativ nah beieinander zum ende
der letzten folge wie weit kannst du
dennoch weg sein ich bin nicht gut darin
ab koordinaten zu laufen bei mir um mich
herum explodiert irgendwas hier sind
leute glaubt ihr es ja aber ich sehe da
oben auch im namen ich weder namen
überall was mache ich habe keine ahnung
und jetzt wollen wir halt warten bis die
anderen vom server herunter sind dann
ganz schnell drauf schauen dann wieder
weglaufen weil ihr kennt ja unsere auch
folgen eigentlich schauen wie die ganze
zeit nur aber hört es ist 19 16 13
semester more game und pari nicht jetzt
im moment eine folge veröffentlichen
dann dürfen sie okay so 16.30
aktualisiere weil sie es jetzt gerade
noch nicht verstanden hat
in dem moment war mister morgen und ari
gerade drei folgen im voraus an dabei
waren nicht mehr als drei folge
produzieren einfach damit das nächste
die situation kommen dass beispielsweise
ein team gerade 100 folgen hat und das
andere team gerade fünf folgen und die
mit 100 folge natürlich viel krassere
altersarmut die mit fünf folgen direkt
töten können die regeln macht sinn die
regel super gut und max und ich haben
uns auf diese regel verlassen und wir
wussten ob playlist am morgen mussawi
haben gerade ihre dritte folge zu ende
aufgenommen und auch ihren kanal war die
vierte folge noch nicht online das heißt
wir wollten diese zeit nutzen bis die
folge von den online geht um auf den
server zu gehen und abzuhauen und das
haben wir jetzt halt gemacht wir sollten
darauf können wir können auf luca okay
ich hab gedacht ich hab geträumt
da falle ich finde der fall wo bist du
ich bin ein
ich würde nach vater keke baulich weg
über den amerikaner nach geträumt
ich betone ich methode könnte gut ohne
ich vertraut nein
glückwunsch luca
aber
die dürfen gar nicht aufnehmen stimmt
die die öffentliche aufnehmen die haben
mich getötet oder hat arrivas
veröffentlicht mister x games auch auf
dem server das scheißegal
wir dürfen nicht aufnehmen okay ich bin
anscheinend fälschlicherweise
rausgeflogen
ok wird spielt checken das nochmal und
luca wird euch bestimmt jetzt mal ein
werden ob es stimmt ob ihr recht hatten
aber falls das fälschlicherweise
geschehen ist
ich schreib doch schon die gruppe er
darf nicht vier folgen im voraus
aufnehmen
hi
ich hoffe ihr habt irgendwie verstanden
was in dieser folge passiert ist fakt
ist auf jeden fall der tot in faro ist
unwiderruflich das heißt auch wenn
dienst wright begangen haben auch wenn
die gar nicht hätten aufnehmen dürfen
ich bin trotzdem draußen
ich kann nicht wiederbelebt werden in
warum ist das was ich sagen will die
sache ist dass eigentlich nichts falsch
gemacht hat mit der morgen eigentlich
schon
und da ist auch noch was krasses
passiert mit ihm aber ich werde dazu
heute abend noch mal ein video hochladen
wo ich mir jetzt gerade so eine art
skript zu schreiben und das ganze noch
mal so ein bisschen revue passieren
lasse was ist jetzt überhaupt passiert
weil das weiß natürlich nicht und
standard kampf okay wir treffen uns nach
zehn folgen wir sind alle vorbereitet
und wir kämpfen und der verlierer
scheidet aus es war halt nicht so ein
einfacher tod in meinem tod inhalt viele
komponenten zusammen also allein dass
meine koordinaten gepostet wurden waren
nur weil ich vier millisekunden
rausgeschnitten hatte aus der ersten
folge es ist jetzt ein rauswurf aus dem
projekt erfolgt wegen meinem tod
also essen viele krasse sachen passiert
die ich so jetzt gar nicht spontan hier
an meinem schreibtisch für euch in die
kamera zusammenfassen kann deswegen habe
ich mir halt gesagt ich lade heute abend
um 19 uhr noch mal ein statement zu dem
tod hoch wo ich nochmal alles
zusammenfassen was passiert ist was
jetzt für auswirkungen hat
also 19 uhr in ein paar stunden konnten
langes statement video nochmals dieser
ganzen sache
naja das war es mit war oh ich hoffe ich
konnte euch unterhalten ich hoffe ich
konnte euch irgendwie zum lachen bringen
zum engsten bringen vor der kamera bei
uns war ja quasi spannung pur angesagt
und ich glaube jeder wusste auch von
beginn an dass max und richtig
kandidaten sind die das projekt für sich
entscheiden werden oder alle anderen
töten werden wir wollten das halten aber
dazu werde ich in dem statement wie die
heute abend kommen da wollte ich ganz
ganz viele sachen noch loswerden
das war für meine damen und herren ich
hoffe euch jetzt gefallen wird es getan
hat las man fett like das geld mal über
alle meine kommentare hashtag sieger der
herzen einfach aber das ist so traurig
dass maxi mich nicht länger überlebt
haben aber max liebt ja noch deswegen
schaut auf jeden fall max kanal vorbei
beschreibung und verlinkt dort jetzt auf
jeden fall weitergehen mit pharo ich
werde dort mit kommentieren allerdings
halten nicht live im spielgeschehen mit
dabei sein wenn ihr uns allerdings so
als minecraft team vermisst dann kann
ich euch mal was gutes sagen und zwar am
zwölfter werden max und ich ein neues
projekt in minecraft machen
zehn folgen lang wo wir vom 22 12
bis 31.12 also die letzten zehn tage im
jahr 2016 in minecraft mit einem moped
was ihr euch jetzt eventuell aussuchen
können schreibt vielleicht etwas in die
kommentare wir werden uns aus
verschiedenen challenges stellen ja so
ein bisschen vivaro nur ohne war
ihr seht hier oben ein smiley
eingeblendet wenn ihr darauf könnte
meinen kanal abonnieren ist kostenlos
und nehmen automatisch am gewinnspiel
für eine playstation 4 teil hier oben
findet ihr mein job eingeblendet und
hier findet ihr mann war teil 1 und den
letzten war urteil also gebt euch die
beiden teile noch mal von sohn fand ich
die besten gewesen
tschüss